wednesday pft pm franchise tag deadline
day has come and gone and the biggest
name
obviously quarterback dak prescott of
the dallas cowboys no deal done which
means he can
only play under a one-year contract he's
already signed his franchise 10 to 31.4
million that's what he'll make this year
next year they'll do it all over again
they can't do a long-term deal until the
2020 regular season ends hopefully there
is one and then at that point the
cowboys will have to decide
do we sign into a long-term deal do we
franchise tag him again
or do we let him walk away as a free
agent now the transition tag next year
probably not an option for the cowboys
because either way he gets a 20 increase
over that 31.4 million dollar franchise
tag salary for this year it's 37.68
transition tag or franchise tag for next
year so if they're going to do one or
the other it's presumably the franchise
tag there are people out there who are
speculating the cowboys won't tag back
again next year
that no one will pay him 37.68 million
basically he should have taken the best
deal he could have gotten with the
cowboys now here's the problem with that
thinking
the cowboys chose the highest possible
level of the franchise tag this year for
dak prescott they've already made it
clear that they believe in dak prescott
unless they would be willing to admit
that they regret
using the highest level of the franchise
tag to keep that prescott around to
prevent him from even talking to another
team to completely slam the door on the
possibility of someone signing into an
offer sheet with two first-round picks
as compensation unless they would say
they were wrong to do that then it's a
no-brainer 37.68 million becomes what he
gets next year barring a catastrophic
injury or a dramatic decrease in his
skills and abilities 69.08 million over
the next two years and then
45 million
plus under the transition tag in 2022 or
54 million plus in 2022 under the
franchise tag or walk away as a free
agent like kirk cousins did a couple of
years ago
that's what the future holds for dak
prescott it's that simple in the
immediate future he gets a raise from 2
million in football salary in 2019 to
31.4 million in 2020. that is not a bad
increase
as increases go
anytime the increase is in the hundreds
of percents
or as the case may be
thousands of percents
that's a pretty good raise over what you
made last year so a 29.4 million dollar
bump for dak prescott to do the same job
that he did
last year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports